[Music]
hi I'm Greg Coburn subject-matter expert
AWS lambda for simply learn I have over
16 years experience working in the IT
industry across many verticals and from
small startups to established
enterprises I have been working with AWS
for approximately eight years and have
completed all five AWS certifications
working with teams large and small and
across several technologies as both a
developer and operations engineer and
managing and mentoring teams has
provided me with a huge amount of
insight into how people learn and
interact with each other and technology
as an avid technology enthusiast I've
been volunteering with STEM education
organizations and in my spare time I
build projects utilizing cloud embedded
systems and Amazon Alexa echoes it's an
amazing time to be alive as the world is
changing at the fastest rate ever and
technology is a very exciting field to
be in as a technologist you must never
stop learning and being curious what is
AWS lambda
AWS lambda is a function as a service
also known as if AAAS offering from AWS
lambda also allows you to run small
snippets of code that perform a very
specific function in either a request
response mode or a batch mode you do not
need to setup and manage a fleet of
servers to scale out and adjust as load
increases and decreases but instead you
leave much of the operational burden to
AWS why should you use lambda you can
build whole applications using lambda
and other AWS services these types of
applications have been coined serverless
application
while strictly speaking there are seven
involved you don't need to manage them
you can also use lamda to provide
operational glue or application glue or
to perform specific batch operations as
part of your application system course
offerings introduction to AWS lambda
course will provide an overview of how
to get started using AWS lamda in
interacting with other AWS services to
do complete systems to provide to
improve your workflow this course will
introduce you to the AWS lambda console
basic I am security setup for lamda
cloud watch logging and metrics and
reviewing cloud trail logs we will also
provide and sign in to how to deploy
several languages to lamda via the
command line as well as the console we
will review the limits and how the lamda
cost model works once you understand the
basics we'll jump into building simple
example functions to interact with AWS
services that you can take away in use
today in your IT operations regardless
of your previous experience we cover
integration with AWS cloud watch events
cloud formation SNS api gateway s3
Kinesis and dynamo dv3 finally we will
provide some examples of third-party
tooling documentation and quick
introduction of DPC endpoints and the
AWS mobile sdk we hope you'll walk away
with new ideas that you can take with
you to start automating your IT
operations or building the next biggest
serverless application simply learns
introduction to AWS lambda course
comprises four hours of elearning quiz
questions at the end of each lesson and
one evaluative project teaching
assistants support from the simply
learned staff at any time during the
court
and for projects queries can also be
submitted it at help and support on
simply learn comm or get connected with
staff on simple talk and live chat
options prerequisite for this course is
a limited understanding of AWS products
and services and some rudimentary
understanding of a programming language
Python nodejs
or java preferred and that's about it go
ahead and begin introduction to AWS
lambda calls and get started with the
first lesson happy learning